all right good so we are live i am here
again with jen this is our fourth
official google plus hangout it's been a
little bit since they're our last one
yeah is it two weeks i think it was
longer now maybe I know it's been longer
I said a few weeks oh you're weeks okay
yeah so what's going on my I've been
super busy so I um gosh i have refined
my website a little bit I kind of
settled on the much name instead of you
so much much is going to be my official
business name and my website still you
so much calm but I kind of have made
adjustments to kind of simplify it and
use much as the official business name
so my twitter handle has been updated
and I set up a YouTube channel and I put
that video up fit um I showed last time
in our last call yeah that was great
how's that how's the reaction to that
it's been good it's been good I actually
sent it off to about a week after I um
actually a few days after I got it up on
the youtube channel i said i found out
some contacts at that company and so i
sent it out to them and i haven't heard
back yet though i haven't heard back but
it's funny because they had this
automatic response saying something like
will give that to you in two days so i
think it's a good sign i haven't heard
back i think they're passing it off to
other people internally which that's my
fantasy I like good yeah what else yeah
and um and then I've worked on a couple
other videos I'm not done yet but I have
recorded one and I've script to the
other and I decided to kind of do
different videos one on headlines
another one on a website page so kind of
touching on different things you could
do copywriting for okay some more
practical hands-on how can you make that
more you like more fantasies if you're
talking about headlines well that's
funny you should ask because it's in the
video but um it's when you are crafted a
headline or sales page or anything you
got to keep in mind what your customers
fantasies is right you gotta eat what
their dreams are what their desires are
what they really want
and so um it's not always going to be as
fantasy um as obvious as a fantasy as
maybe the product descriptions work for
the bras right but it's still tapping
into the rooms and desires and making
sure talking to the right person and so
um it'll be obvious when you see them
that you know you know how I did that so
for example what one of the videos is on
Keanu my client oh so bold and heard the
the video that I'm doing is about her
start here page which can sometimes be
really boring right it's kind of like go
visit my website Mina my about page go
you know like me on Facebook it kind of
like directions the different places you
know to see if you like her brand and a
lot of start here pages are like that
they just kind of direct you to check
them out right and so instead of just
making it really boring i used a fantasy
by making it about a shoe shopping
experience so it's kind of a metaphor
for shoe shopping so you know first you
gotta check out the displays then you
gotta try them on and that kind of thing
and so it was a fantasy in that regard
if that makes sense ok and her target
customer is someone who really loves to
go shoe shopping so um you know it's
moving again it's maybe not as obvious
as like the the product description is
but it's still tapping into people's
fantasies mm-hmm and had she put it up
yeah it's up okay so you're just
breaking down we talked about that on
last video right breaking jebet yeah
breaking down how I how I wrote it
exactly how i came up with that idea and
you know how famous he plays into that
yeah I would love to see you kind of tap
into just to lead that off to the top
and two did you were to record this
video I most of it yeah okay but I'm
helping to your suggestions cuz I you
know I can change it I haven't it's not
edited yet okay yeah what I'd love to
see is leading off with the pain okay um
you know here's this something opinion
everybody can relate to so here's his
entrepreneur who has a website she's a
she's a coach right right exactly yeah
but what's wrong
our website right so she set up this
website to get business it's not giving
any business you look at her page it's
the same thing everybody else has she
doesn't have anything exciting
meaningful and so you're here to come
and help her okay like leading off with
that is easier to relate to then here's
why you know this video is about
headlines like who cares about headlines
it's not about headlines right right
that's that's that might be the answer
but you gotta start with the problem
okay um if that doesn't mess up your
video too much no no it doesn't it
doesn't it can rearrange things i like
your suggestion actually yeah just like
honey i just heard her mean maybe well
make me feel her pain make me feel like
I am what's her name again keanu Jana so
I'm keanu like oh man I'm Keanu I'm
going to do that same thing my website
sucks I don't know what's wrong with it
I don't know why people are in contact
people are visiting my site and nobody
contacts me what's happening right like
that right let's does your copy sucks
right because there's nothing unique
about you so if you make me feel that
pain then I'm going to be more
interested in not only listen to the
video but I'm more engaged and I'm gonna
be more likely to follow up and want to
contact you as my fancy copyright right
okay that makes sense cool I'm excited
to see that wait I think you were
supposed to have this done though by the
time we had this call Jack I was I was
it was not an injured I was I was gonna
have it done but I I just don't I i
actually have most of it died i just
didn't have anything done in time so my
12 year old editor just didn't have the
time in her busy schedule oh just do it
for 88 report of the work come on I know
I know I labor here totally aren't you
she did a great job though you guys that
was an amazing first video yeah thank
you she did do my job I I definitely
could have done without her actually
it's funny because when i did that first
video I kind of did it all like i
videotape myself and then had her at
and put in like the screenshots and all
that and um and I kind of did it all in
one take for me like I practice what I
could just do the whole like five minute
talk and one take but then when she put
in the different screenshots I she had
to redo my voiceover so it's kind of
flights because this time I was like
okay whew I don't have to have a whole
thing you know like you know error-free
for you know five to ten minutes however
long videos so it's kind of nice because
now I i can come up relax a little bit
of any about and what's the next one um
and so i'm going to do another one so
hers is about a start here page and then
the other one i was going to do is that
um was i was actually gonna take one of
your pages off your route whoo good all
right I know right I thought it might
give you a little bored he let you see
it first to make sure you're cool with
it I'm cool i'll do whatever I'm cool
with it I'm gonna make a little yeah so
I'm going to take your passion Zuko page
and also talked a little about headlines
with that one okay so is there another
topic you can kind of quick besides
headlines um yeah yeah I could I could
talk to just in general about sales
pages um you know about and also bullet
points because um you know that's a
great opportunity to use them bullet
points and there's no bullet points on
that page there's a few things about
that page I've actually done most a copy
already a sound on the video okay do you
have do you have a process do you have
like a ten steps according to jen of
perfect copywriting yeah yeah i do go
through a process we talking about this
right i mean you kind of mentioned a
process a little bit in that in that
first video yeah I did so I mean my main
process I mean that one was I kind of
simple oversimplified it a little bit
yeah so that the video wasn't too long
last time right you know in in the in
the one that I did for keyonna I talked
a little bit my process of like knowing
who your target customer is you know
figuring out their fantasies are what
they really want their real you know
what the real desire is here and then
also how they want to feel and then
using all those when you're crafting the
copy so that's coming that's kind of the
main process I go through for you know
oh my oh my copy so if it kind of covers
it okay I'm thinking
if we drill down a little deeper on some
of those so the things that you
mentioned was you need to have a good
headline to have bullet points so that
talks like readability and ease of flow
of reading through the copy uh there's
probably a whole bunch of those that you
just do naturally yeah you're right that
you don't uh you may not even written it
down and say here's what I do okay what
educating people through that process so
it's not like if you can distill it down
points right and then each video could
cover a different points if you're
talking about so you have your headline
videos coming out that's great so she
has her headline video maybe mine is
about uh flow okay right hey well Evans
page sucks because there's no bullet
points and there's no pictures and it's
one big Chuck attacks or whatever it is
right and so if you had like these this
list of whatever it is ten things seven
things one things that kind of you look
for you helped create with your copy
then that can help guide people through
a series of your of how you think but it
also gives you lots of different types
of videos to make when you're breaking
down papi yeah I see what you're saying
it's not like okay here's another
headline video and here's another
headline video here's another headline
Vidya right like we covered headline
let's move on to other gang come back
with maybe in a couple months sure well
I like it because I instead I was kind
of going through my own process of you
know almost like the foundation like
where I start from I wasn't even
thinking about like a process you know
process of the of the page itself which
you're right that it's kind of natural
for me but it might not be natural for
someone else well I got no expertise
that you have internalized right most
people will have no idea about yeah
right and again our goal here is to
educate mm-hmm you have the thought
leaders for the people who can't afford
your services will still have something
that can help them right can afford know
at the time say well generally as she's
doing a hire her
right so explaining your process and
easy to digest okay words makes it makes
it easier to that Jack's right you want
it to be easy to do business with you
yeah absolutely okay I love it so almost
like the mechanics of the actual page
itself yeah you can think about like
maybe go to the like a page that just
totally sucks and it's not even just the
copy because it's not fantasy but
everything is off like one big ugly
chunk of text and whatever it is yeah
and sometimes by finding all of the bad
things on a page that helps you define
you know what you'd like that's good
right yeah yeah well there are certain
things about certain pages like for
example about pages a lot of people
write about pages that are all about
them like all like it just says how
great they are oh this is all about me
and they think that people like that
when well some goes their website that
they want to know all about that person
which they often do but they also want
to feel like they're taught you know
talking to that like so if you just
rephrase how you put something on in the
valve page you know I wonder if it makes
sense to show like good website examples
and bad ones too like as I'm talking
about a specific kind of page yeah you
can I like exposing you as the expert
and showing off like it's a good
opportunity to show off what you can do
if you take a bad one you can show up
how you would make it better okay one
you can see why it's good but it doesn't
feel like it's because it shows off me
right listen for you um even as you're
talking here you're already going
through different categories of how to
make a good sales letter as an example
so this can be confusing because you're
jumping buckets yes I mean you make
those steps easily because you're the
expert but for somebody watching it
doesn't it's not as it's not as linear
so right for example you're talking
about on an about page people talk to us
about them and they're still
right but that's a different set of
points then you have to make it readable
and you need to have good headlines and
you need to have bullet points right cuz
I can make my about page with a great
headline and greet bullet points and
pictures and slow but it's still the
wrong content right right so there are
two different points like those points
don't belong in the same video right
okay you got a dumb it down and make it
simple for somebody who doesn't
understand your business to digest it
because they're already feeling
overwhelmed by their copy okay where for
you those love those mental leaps are
nothing you'd like you're just he's
right hi put it out right right in five
seconds and people watching it like
their their heads gonna blow up sure
okay so it maybe you just getting that
down on paper the types of things that
are wrong or maybe just make a list of
everything that is wrong with a bad page
and then categorize those right just
like in our Zukas we have the survival
marketing raising capital and time those
are distinct chunks right what if I
talked about time management and
marketing at the same time I'm spending
too much information people will start
to get lost not yet okay so you can
write down like your list of 30 things
or whatever it is and then group them
into maybe three buckets that makes the
most sense yeah and then each one of
those can become its own video and so
that you're not repeating yourself for
you know ten weeks or 12 weeks or
whatever it is right are used to do this
every two weeks right that was the goal
oh yeah that's the goal yep really cool
man come on let's go okay okay your
daughter to work I know exactly gotta
get her on a schedule too gotta go you
know that's all organized but no I agree
and Ashley if I love this idea because I
think the other thing is is as I'm
approaching other businesses i can send
them examples with these videos like
okay I noticed on your page your
headline sucks whatever check out this
video and then they can get a good
feeling for what I'm talking about yeah
more specifically
they also get a feeling my personality
cuz i'm on the video so I I just love
this idea yeah yeah and when you go and
you talk to a local business they will
you know if you have 30 things that you
have to do right they may only have like
one or two that they have going right
for them but you can pick the one most
offensive thing that they're doing wrong
you know that like gets your blood
boiling because it's just so wrong the
worst thing they're doing right the
video just on that right I'm not
overwhelm them with here's all the
things that are happening on your site
okay yeah yeah no I love it yeah okay so
when does this video coming up again and
we're pushing your daughter for like
next week yeah I'm gonna have well I
mean I'm my goals to have them both done
by next week yeah okay they're gone yeah
yeah okay but now you have to change the
topic on Mars it's not headlines yeah
it's okay that's okay I'll just change a
little bit yeah they'll be easy yeah it
may even be something that as you get it
refined you could show um like a picture
at the start to say okay we're talking
like you to you have your free buckets
right we're talking about this bucket
just structure we're talking about
structure today and here are like here's
jen's I put in the gin you're the
tenting no today we're talking about
number three which is oh here's a crappy
website on flow and then you just so
that people know there's a lot more and
it gives them you know excitement to
wait for your next video talk what
number four okay you don't like don't
let that hold you back from just doing
your videos mm-hmm because you can get
still stuck in your head figuring that
out that you don't end up doing anything
mm-hmm but as you define your
methodology better that can help give
clarity for you on the types of videos
to make but also clarity for your
audience and something to look forward
to every week for every two weeks right
that's a good suggestion yeah and it
shows that there's a lot more to you
ain't when I'm talking my headlines
today but hey I got you part of a
10-step process that i go through but
today we only talked about headline
right right well it gives a little more
focused to like you said probably makes
it easier for them to watch it yeah yeah
it's a good suggestion
absolutely cool how was your you're
gonna update your homepage to with uh
more yeah I did update my homepage all
right good looks really awesome i
completely changed it so when you go
there actually what if i could um share
the screen with you sure um okay let's
see i can reduce here we go um that's
good maybe one yeah I hit the button now
just gonna figure out like that's not
the right one uh uh okay ah ok now where
did you go dr. D will be a video for
your your you could show up your video
and the evolution that you went through
before and after of your homepage yeah
that's good idea your old biddy of your
old home page and a new home page cuz
it's to the elder home page basically
had kind of um I just had some coffee
about copyrighting to appeal to a
business owner and then it had like a
email signup and so instead what i did
was i changed it to what's wrong with
that there's nothing wrong with it but
there was nothing about fantasy on there
at all well so what's wrong with that
well because that's what I'm all about
but this is important read like don't
jump to the answer without telling me
the problem right okay look so I you
know I'm a copywriter I had a great copy
of my sight but it didn't speak to who I
was right I have a change in here's how
I went to the process and here's how you
can to or here's how i can help you go
through that right yeah like change for
the sake of change isn't good but
explaining the reason because people can
go they're gonna be on the same line
with you where they have a website they
just have some copy up there and they
realize hey i wanna i want to stand for
something to I want my website look
different so that's that's how you
connect them to be watching your video
because they don't need the answers
until they understand the problem okay
great okay I don't know if you still
have your old website a homepage cocky
to kind of compare to what I could make
a fun video oh that's a good idea i
don't know if i do
that yeah I don't know if I ever took a
screenshot of that would have been a
good idea I pick a screenshot my bad
page but not my homepage huh well maybe
don't get maybe I can recreate it um so
yeah let me I can um let me show you
right now what I do with my website okay
can you see me I see me okay how do you
see this okay so so you can see here now
it's got um it's all about fantasy so
there's a there's just a tile here
that's moving it has basically a little
mini fantasy on story on it so it says
right away to anyone who's reading it
like you know here's an example of a
fantasy and then what I'm asking people
to do is share their fantasy with me um
because that's what I'm all about and I
feel like um you know business owners
don't ever get the opportunity to share
their own fantasy with me and I can much
better write copy for someone if they're
willing to share you know what their
fantasies are um and so that's kind of
instead of a typical email update you
know L hey sign up for my email updates
I want them to tell me their fantasy and
then instead of like of some free be
that's you know kind of generic I'm
going to surprise them buy it now it's
how surprised if anyone watches this but
surprised them by writing back to them
with a Reaper afton fantasy so it's more
in a storytelling kind of format the way
that it is up here on the screen so has
anybody nobody yet no oh look that the
one on top the ones that scroll are
fools yes that's the idea and then you
want them to do their own below right
exactly and then with their permission
I'd love to add more up here you know of
different business owners fantasies so
yeah I like I like you know it's it's
bulb I like it because the people who
are gonna fill that out some people
gonna look at that and say share your
fantasy would like this is stupid right
right yeah like they're never going to
be a great client for you but the ones
who do are more aligned with what you're
thinking the only thing I had a little
bit of a disconnect between that cop bar
and share your fantasy I'm wondering are
you had something in that bar that said
like my fantasy
is and then right and then you put the
fantasy so if you get this you get the
only thing that that's somebody who
wrote in or here's an example yeah okay
you had that little thing on the top
right like fantasy number two thousand
right exactly that was the idea so they
would get idea that was a fantasy yeah
yeah I was it was maybe on up for me
maybe was just a little too subtle where
it starts as my fantasy is you know
semicolon and then you write a guy yeah
and then share your fantasy might make a
little more sense something to play with
I don't know I like it though it's
different yeah that's what I was going
for well in it really I mean I really do
I mean I really do believe like the
people that I have worked with that have
shared their fantasies with me I just
feel like their coffee so much better
because I get what they're all about do
you know to mean and again who their
customers are so um it's kind of almost
like hey if you can't share if you see
with me then you know i'm not sure if
I'm the right you know person work with
right yeah very cool so did I put this
back on the screen are we back normal I
try I see you again okay guy get good so
it's not a few minutes left what else
any anything else you want to go over
well the only other thing I was curious
about I have a feeling to know your
answers but i thought i'd ask anyway um
on twitter one of the ideas i had was to
share fantasy stories on twitter um and
I was kind of going back and forth about
should I just put it on my own Twitter
handle and just kind of like you know
hashtag you know much fantasy or
something like that so it's like a
little indication that it's a little
fantasy story or would it be better to
set up a new twitter handle that's all
about it's all this is fantasy stories
and then just and then just on my own
Twitter handle like you know promote it
through that it as an example and what
do you think my answer would be to keep
it on man to handle you're right because
listen fantasy is you right right so
your own twitter handle is all about
fantasy anyway even if I'm telling
stories it's fantasies something else
right right right now recognizing
somebody who's living out their fantasy
but
yeah the stuff you share you can't you
can't help but make it about fantasy
because that's who you are right right
no I agree i've just seen other authors
do something similar to this and I've
always wondered like okay you know
what's the thought here like are they
doing it because they want to really
separate from you know their own you
know personality or are they just are
they doing because they have more
character space you know I mean like I
mean as simple as that is you know that
is probably a factor but um I don't know
I I like the idea to vent oh man twitter
handle too so I just thought I'd ask but
you thought even though I knew I knew
you'd say good yeah all right so you uh
you have some videos to send me I'm
excited hopefully for our next call so i
could take a look or maybe we'll do it
live again maybe we'll do a live again i
like that i like watching it live okay
yeah let's do it live again alright cool
I love it let's do it lark great cool
okay thanks Jay I'm sorry Kevin good to
see you in a bike